(cheerful techno music)
(crowd chattering)
- So, my name is Nadya
Bair and I'm a post doc
in Digital Humanities
and American Studies.
So my project is called
The Decisive Network,
Magnum Photos and the
Postwar Image Market.
And it's related to my book
manuscript which is a history
of the photo agency Magnum.
So something that I was
really interested in
is Magnum is really known for a couple
of its famous photographers
and their iconic images
that they produced, and what
I was interested in doing
is a couple of things.
First, based on the archival
research that I did,
showcasing the labor of other staff
who helped the photographers become famous
and who helped them produce their works.
So the largest view here is
dedicated to really bringing
to life people like
secretaries and editors.
People who worked behind the scenes
on editing Magnum films and
distributing Magnum Films.
Another part of the project
that I'm interested in doing
is showing how agents, sales agents,
sold Magnum's pictures around the world.
So, the idea is to have a map of the world
showing how post, and after World War 2,
magazine markets emerged
and how Magnum was servicing
those markets with its pictures.
And then the third part
is to pick a couple
of iconic photo stories and to show
how they also circulated around the world
and the intervention there is,
especially in the United States,
we often think about
photo journalism history
as being about Life magazine,
and the goal here is to show
that these photographers
were selling to a whole variety of markets
and that they were actually influencing
global visual culture and not
just American visual culture
with the pictures they were producing.
It's been really great to collaborate
with a digital humanities lab at Yale,
particularly because I found that a lot
of the pre-existing software
on network visualization
sort of all looked the same
and put you into a mold
of having to represent
networks in a particular kind
of 21st century way, and
what I really wanted to do
was to represent these
networks and these ideas
in the style of postwar visual cultures.
So, the designer Monica Ong Reed,
I showed her some of
the publicity materials
that Magnum was creating about itself
and so what we've done is we've come up,
she's come up with ways
to model the presentation
of this information on that
mid-century visual culture
and that's really exciting to me.
- The basis for the project
is a tool to explore
the testimonies of Holocaust survivors,
witnesses and bystanders
from 3 different collections,
the Fortunoff video archive, which has,
is a collection of 4,500 testimonies,
the USC Shoah Foundation,
and the US Holocaust Memorial Museum.
Both the USC Shoah Foundation and
the US Holocaust Memorial
Museum have contributed
over 1,000 testimony transcripts
each to this project.
In our collection, combined with that,
comes to about 3,000
testimony transcripts.
The anthology is very much a project
that is similar to others,
sort of traditional,
historical work in which
a body of text is explored
and similar experiences
are brought together
from those texts to explore more,
let's say, common experiences
that survivors may have met
in the camps or prior to
or in the post war period.
The anthology however, uses sophisticated
data text mining tools to
explore this very large amount
of data in order to pull those
common experiences together.
The other aspect of this
project is a search tool
which allows researchers and educators
to search across all of these
3,000 testimony transcripts
in sophisticated ways to locate subjects
related to their research topics.
So there's really two
sides to the project,
the anthology and the search tool.
Fortunoff Video Archive in the DHLab
had started a partnership
beyond this project.
This is our, sort of first
effort to work them together
by bringing Gabor Toth, the
post doctoral associate.
We are funding the post
doctoral associate,
and the DHLab is
working together with him
to produce this project.
But in addition to this we're also looking
to bring in a developer to work
on additional Fortunoff
projects in the future.
- My name is Amanda Chemeche.
I am a dual degree Masters
student at Yale University.
So I'm studying East Asian
studies and American studies.
But both of them have an
interest in the history,
the landscape and trauma that
takes place in the landscape,
and investigating that
with digital media tools
such as Autocad, Rhino
and Adobe Illustrator.
So, yah.
It's actually based off of
Teju Cole's novel, Open City.
And the protagonist is Julius and Julius
is a Nigerian doctor
at Columbia University
who traverses the city and
meditates on various events
historically that have happened,
and one of the main quotes of the book
is that the site is a palimpsest,
and a palimpsest is a
document where things
have been written on it
and erased and re-written.
You can find the imprint of those things
from the past in that document.
And when you think about
atrocity and the development
of Manhattan, like, you
know, wait a minute,
my fiance is an architecture student
and we're using exploded
axons all the time,
and what's a better
document, kind of, expressor,
than an exploded axon to show
the palimpsest of history?
So we picked four, four points
that Teju Cole talked about,
which was pre-colonial
Manhattan when it was occupied
by the Algonquin Lenape.
Dutch colonial Manhattan, we picked 1664,
right on the cusp of when
it was sold to the British.
1863 draft riots and
2001, the 9-11 attacks.
And we really wanted
to express two things.
We wanted to talk about the
fact that he's articulating
all this information,
but when you're talking
about literature, you're cherry picking
pieces of information from
within a broader archive,
and we wanted to compare those two things.
And in order to do that, we
traced out his experiences,
this is a programmatic axon.
So that really shows these events
layered on one another and
then separated by time.
And at the same time, we
recreated from historic maps,
these 3 dimensional interactive
spaces that have hot spots,
and as you click on them,
you open up the archives.
So I wanted people to understand
the wealth of information
that he was tapping into and begin
to actually explore these spaces.
So it's kind of like time
travel in four distinct periods.
- What I'm presenting
here is a Python module.
It's a software module
and it's designed for use
inside of the Jupyter
Computational notebook format.
And the idea is that
if you're a researcher
who is working with a lot of image data,
and in particular, if
you want to get, sort of,
human eyes on the data,
there are some very, kind of,
concise ways of producing
montages of images.
Let me show you an example of this.
Sort of these montages of
images and they can be sorted
according to visual
properties of the images,
or according to meta data
variables like place and time,
and the idea is in particular,
if you're a researcher in
the Humanistic Sciences
and you want your human expertise
to be the primary way of
apprehending these images,
rather than, sort of
like, machine perception,
this enables you to get
human eyes on your images
in a fairly efficient way,
without having to leave
the computational notebook format.
One thing I've learned in
the process of producing
this software is I had to
try to strike a balance,
in this case between the,
kind of, power of the tool,
and what I mean by that
is the ability of the tool
to do lots of different things,
and then for it to be
learnable by a fairly, kind of,
sort of a new audience that is
learning it for the first time.
It can be a little bit
overwhelming if the tool has like,
too many features, and so
you want to strike a balance
between lots of features and
something being learnable
and sort of, the user being
able to conceptualize it
fairly easily in the beginning,
and so I decided on having just
four or five very basic plotting functions
and that have a number of
options that you can change
to adjust features of the plots
and I found that to be
a fairly good balance.
So there is a lot of power in there
but the tool is organized
according to a fairly simple model
that I think the user can,
kind of, learn right away.
And so, this originally was
designed for the use case where,
maybe you're already coding
in Python a little bit
and you know a little bit of that stuff,
but I think it could be an entry point
for some people who want to learn that,
but it's a little daunting and I think
that is is kind of like a gentle entry
into using Python and the notebook format.
- This was collection of 300
or so tweets that we took.
And what this is doing
is reading the tweets
in chronological order, and
every time it comes across
one of these key words,
it'll ping the bubble.
And so the darker and larger the bubble,
the more commonly it's seen,
and it's really interesting
because you can watch
the composition of
what's being talked about
in the tweets as the
movement is going through.
And a couple of interesting
things were Calhoun
was initially not something
was brought up in the tweets.
It was initially a lot of
master, a lot of slavery,
a lot of civil rights, and
then as the movement went on,
we see a lot of increased
attention to community, to campus,
to principles, that kind of thing.
So this was just an
interesting way to visualize
what was happening in the
evolution of the tweets.
This is the same set of tweets but instead
what's happening is here is, sort of,
the first tweets chronologically
and then it goes around in this direction,
and what you can do is you can
sort of put your mouse
over top of the words
and it will map to where
they appear in the tweet.
So you can take a look
at, for example, Yale.
It's really prominent in
the first couple of tweets
and in the later sections
it's not so prominent.
For students, more prominent
in the later tweets
than it is in the earlier
tweets, that kind of thing.
It's just another way to
visualize what's happening
in the tweets.
- My name is Gina Hurley.
I am an a Medieval Studies PhD candidate.
- My name is Eric Ensley
and I am a PhD student
in the English Department.
- So we are presenting an
addition that was developed
during a graduate student
workshop, the Digital Editing
and the Manuscript Roll workshop,
of which we've now hosted
several institutions.
- Yes, and it's a two day workshop
and we invite graduate
students and librarians,
basically anybody studying
anything having to do
with the Medieval period,
to come to our workshop
and we train them to do XML and TEI.
And so over the course of the workshop,
they design and implement code
for a digital edition of a roll,
and we are hosting that
on our website right now,
and we are running through our
beta version of our platform.
And we will have an archive of about,
we have about 10 rolls
right now that we've done.
We will be hosting all those rolls online.
So it's collaborative coding basically.
- So Manuscript rolls are unusual objects,
and so trying to find a way to do justice
to the actual physical
materiality of a manuscript roll,
when most of our, most of the
existing mark up languages
are thinking about codices,
of books, as opposed to this,
you know, strange, long
object that you have to unroll
and interact with in this
really interesting way.
Thinking about a way that
our editions can do justice
to the materiality of a
manuscript is something
that we've been really interested in.
- My name is Nathan Lin and I am
an undergraduate Computer
Science major at Yale.
I'm working on a project that
involves making 3D models
of some stone tablets
that we have at Yale.
So, actually, sorry.
In the Art Gallery we
have these stone reliefs
from the Northwest Palace in
Nimrud, so ancient Babylon.
And, one motivation for this project is,
of course in the last couple of years,
ISIS is presumed to have
destroyed this palace.
So one thing we want to do
is work on creating models
of our existing tablets
so that we have some kind
of preservation of them.
And another aspect that I'm working on is
trying to provide the
viewers with an experience
that they wouldn't be able to get
from just going to the art gallery
and looking at the tablets.
So here is my 3D model of the tablet
and one of the things that
I was working on is well,
the lighting we have right
now is really different
from the lighting back 3,000 years ago.
So of course the tablet
is going to look different
if it's lit by modern
lights, versus if it's lit
by what they probably
had, like torch light.
So I've been working on
some different models
of illumination using fire.
So, like then you would be able to cycle
through these different kinds of lighting
and get a better idea of
what these tablets look like,
and one portion that I
am currently working on
where this affective
lighting is really going
to make a difference,
is that I'm working on
trying to reconstruct
what the original coloring
of these tablets would look like,
because these tablets were all
originally painted 3,000 years ago.
If you go to the art
gallery, the other tablet,
at the art gallery you can
actually see like some red
still on the feet of the tablet.
So we're working on
talking to art historians
and conservators,
on what colors the tablet
would have looked like back then.
And that's where the
lighting is really going
to make a big difference
because different colors
are gonna look really different
under kinds of lighting,
'cause it's most likely
that the kinds of colors
they are using would
look very garish today
under normal lighting
but under fire lighting
they'd being much more subdued
and then more aesthetically
pleasing kind of image.
(cheerful techno music)